hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
just checking in on you i'm just
checking in on you to see how the [ __ ]
you're doing
hey you know what i was all excited to
get this [ __ ]
uh uh vaccine and all of that [ __ ] oh
i'm group 1c
1c over 50. come on up and get it
i thought you got it and then that was
it
but now i'm here and you got to get it
then you got to get another one and then
they think maybe it's only good for a
[ __ ] year
it's like oh you greedy [ __ ]
you know how many comedians have done
bits about the last thing they've really
cured was polio now look i know this
thing is brand new
do you know the deal these guys are
licking their chops going there is over
seven billion people on the planet who
need this shot
we're gonna make a ton of money and then
there was one other guy
what if what if they had to get it every
year
seven billion every year
in a bucket um i don't know maybe maybe
i don't know you got to get a flu shot
every year maybe it's just like that i
don't [ __ ] know but i thought i was
going to go down i was going to get it i
was going to be fine
i don't know what are you going to do
what do you do it could be worse right
it could be work it could always be
worse it could always be worse
that's what i've learned it could always
be worse like right now you know what i
mean
as much as you were a fan of donald
trump
okay and you think that they took the
election from him and he got [ __ ] over
and all as much as you thought that
it could always be worse you could have
gone down to d.c
and those [ __ ] idiots with their
water buffalo lodge fred flintstone
[ __ ] hats
went in and killed the [ __ ] cop and
now you could have been there
now listen to what the [ __ ] these these
guys are doing
prosecutors weigh heavy hammer felony
murder for riders and capital
officers police officers death now i
understood that but listen to this [ __ ]
as federal prosecutions uh file charges
against rioters who took part
in last wednesday's violent take over
the u.s capitol
investigators continue to gather
evidence well i guess this is an old
article
well it's new to me last week it was
almost last month
gather evidence in the death of capitol
police officer brian
sicknick who died from injuries
sustained during the attack
while most murder investigations focus
on the person or
persons who caused the fatal injury
former federal prosecutor
uh tim herpe
hippie hiffy i don't know said
prosecutors
could charge many rioters with felony
murder even if they were nowhere near
sicknick see it could be that you could
have been one of those law-abiding
trumpsters standing out there with your
[ __ ] sign
yelling at the cops why don't you go in
there go do something good with one of
them
still getting charged this can always
can always be worse can always be worse
that's that's what i learned this week
you know when you finally fix the
[ __ ] wall in your backyard right
they got to dig up a bunch of vegetation
and then the next time it rains all the
[ __ ] dirt you have your own private
mudslide
and it goes all over your [ __ ] patio
like it did for me this week
could always be worse
could have been you know i don't know
god forbid i could have been standing
there
oh freckles buried up to his neck and
dirt like the end of that [ __ ]
what was that movie there the guy buried
the dude up in the sand waiting for the
tide to come in and he's screaming i can
hold my breath a really long time
i think it was the guy from airplane
oh wasn't that the [ __ ] key was it the
[ __ ] keeper they did a bunch of
different ones
i don't [ __ ] know anyways
anyway you know they should charge with
something these federal prosecutors
these [ __ ] [ __ ] who jog in the
street when there's a perfectly good
[ __ ] sidewalk they jogging
in the street like they're having their
own little [ __ ] uh if anybody noticed
like
bicycle people on bikes and joggers are
getting really aggressive
i don't know what that deal is
this [ __ ] [ __ ] he comes i'm like
driving down the street this guy comes
running out into the street like off a
side street like he's in a car
he's not even on a bicycle he's just
running down the street it's like why
aren't you on the
[ __ ] sidewalk where you belong
sorry i know it shouldn't get to me like
that but why aren't you on the [ __ ]
side this is new me i'm gonna be more
calm
hey buddy buddy why aren't you on the
[ __ ] sidewalk where you belong
you dumb [ __ ] why can't they run on
the [ __ ] there's a sidewalk why can't
you be there
why are you running in the [ __ ]
street you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh you know where to turn my ankle you
know it's more even surface
really so you're gonna run in traffic
with your back to people while they text
and drive
and then what are they gonna do frost
your [ __ ] jogging shorts after you
died to leave it next to the [ __ ]
idiot
who was riding a bike in something that
was called a bike lane that isn't
right [ __ ] people on bikes can go
[ __ ] themselves
okay i'm as i like to try and be green
and all that type of [ __ ] these [ __ ]
[ __ ] on bikes
i've said it a million times they don't
obey the rules of the road they're
supposed to if you'd ride out in the
street you're
just like a car you got a signal when
you turn you got to come to a full stop
at a [ __ ] stop sign i don't even do
that but these [ __ ] [ __ ]
they blow right red lights stop signs
all of this [ __ ] and then when they
die then when they [ __ ] die what do
they do
they frost the bike like they're a
[ __ ] war hero
here lies so and so he rode out in
traffic and didn't stop at red lights
can you believe what [ __ ] these
people in cars are
sorry it really isn't about these people
it's really about the [ __ ]
it's like somebody dug a swimming pool
in my backyard but there isn't one
and they just left the dirt that's what
the [ __ ] happened
all over my patio i'll tell you right
now people be careful what you wish for
you know i'm really starting to see the
genius
of uh those people who live in those
little [ __ ]
like they somehow turn a walk-in closet
into like a house
um how insufferable
is someone who lives in a [ __ ] house
like that
you know they have this big [ __ ]
ear-to-ear grin when you come walking in
there
because they love being the center of
attention which is why they bought that
little house to begin with
now look if you're doing it for
financial reasons okay you're off the
hook but if you're [ __ ] doing it to
make a statement that you're a
minimalist okay that's great i think it
is a good thing it is good for the
[ __ ] environment but i don't want to
come over
i don't want to talk to you you come
walking in there waiting to blow my mind
at how little you can live with and be
happy be happy with
you know okay like
i'm just picturing a guy with a beard
and his hair pulled back in a ponytail
he sort of
saw that brilly hair you know
looks like the drummer in faith no more
except like
smarmy a smarmy version of that guy
that's who i picture when i walk in
he's not wearing a shirt with his dumb
yoga body
you know he's basically doing everything
right and it's [ __ ] annoying me
you know and then you're in that little
house and you know you can't
you can't do anything you're just in
that little house everybody's gonna see
it if you have a fight it's gonna be
like raised in arizona you gotta come
out the side of it
um
i don't know if i didn't have kids i i
really think and i look at those things
sometimes as i'm sitting here looking
around my [ __ ] office
and over the years every gig i've done
somebody gives me something somebody
gives me this i get a free t-shirt and
all this [ __ ]
and the next thing you know next thing
you know you just have a mountain
of [ __ ] [ __ ] i have so much [ __ ]
framed i don't even know what the [ __ ]
to do i don't know what to do with it
and today
i go to the uh the [ __ ] grocery store
it's not it's sort of a mom-and-pop one
because it's owned by like
a family it's weird
it's sort of a weird place where it's
like
it's mom and pop it's super healthy
but they don't like gay people it's in
the valley
they got some [ __ ] for it but they got
the organic [ __ ] so i go there right the
[ __ ]
you know i like gay people you know not
straight across the board because
there's [ __ ] who have to be gay you
know what i mean but i
i don't i don't dislike gay people it's
what i'm trying to say i don't want to
be like oh i like gay people i hate when
people say that
i love the gays all of them
just just all they have to be is be gay
because there's [ __ ] who happen to be
gay
happen to be gay right if you're cool i
like you that's the deal but here's the
thing too i also want to be
in the shape of a gay dude so i i have
to go to where these homophobic people
i don't have to but it's convenient so i
do so anyway i go in there
and as i'm going to leave you know the
lady puts the [ __ ] in the f
in the bag and then she gives me another
bag i go what is that she goes oh it's a
little gift bag from the thing there
right
and what it is is it's either new
products or [ __ ] that isn't selling well
and they're hoping that i'm eating it
and i'm gonna [ __ ] like it
it was like one thing that was edible i
just took a glance at it and then the
other things were all like stuff you had
to open
this little [ __ ] like i'm not like a
giant gift bag like uh like you know
when you brown bagged your lunch it was
like the size of that
and it came up but i opened i was like
what the no what the [ __ ] am i supposed
to do with this
what am i supposed to do with this
a couple of times i've entertained
getting rid of almost everything i have
but i'm too [ __ ] sentimental
but as i'm looking around this office
there's a whole bunch of [ __ ] i'm
thinking like i didn't need to buy that
why did i buy that
like you know what's a bad one a
bookshelf a bookshelf full of books
you probably didn't read most of them
and if you did you're not going back
i have all of these books books that i
loved that i read
so you know someday i'll go back and
read them again you know what you don't
you move on to the next thing and there
it is it's just sitting on your [ __ ]
shelf
all right this is getting dark man this
is getting dark
that's why i'm starting to do podcasts
with other people man you know
left alone to my own thoughts starts
going a little sideways there
um anyway
yeah so i got a bunch of dirt in my
[ __ ] backyard right now
and i have to [ __ ] i don't know what
i got to do with it do we put it back
and then
hey we can plant some more stuff up
there well didn't we take that [ __ ] out
because the [ __ ] you planted up there
was [ __ ] with the wall
does it just go around in a circle is
that is that what happens
you know i'm getting the last bit of the
plumbing done and then my house is done
it's done and you know it's like uh
buddy of mine said owning a house is
it's like painting the [ __ ]
golden gate bridge i said al madrigal
said that i think that's what he said
it's like painting the golden great
bridge and what it is is they paint the
golden gate bridge and they never stop
and when they get all the way to one
side it's time to paint the other and
they just keep that's all they do is
just paint that [ __ ] thing
i mean personally if i was the mayor of
san francisco maybe i'd hire some more
painters
get the [ __ ] job done you know where
they got like three guys working on that
[ __ ] thing
um whatever um
so what did i do today today i actually
forgot i was so [ __ ] busy
i forgot it was thursday so i apologize
i apologize
that the podcast is so goddamn late how
about those boston bruins
winning again in overtime
brad marshawn keeping scoring points
keep scoring
points at a miraculous clip dude we
[ __ ] have had more goddamn over
overtime games and shootouts and i think
we've won every single one of them
um let's see nhl leaders leaders
come on brad's got to be up there he's
got to be up there statistic leaders
okay nhl how hilarious it that i'm going
to espn who could give a
[ __ ] about hockey um all right
offensive leader conor mcdavid he's got
12.
come on where the [ __ ] squish where's
marshawn he's got to be top five he has
to be
he's tied for ninth who [ __ ] in copa
talk kopetar having a great [ __ ] year
this late in his career look at this got
10 points
marshawn's got nine copitar's got 10.
connor mcdavid mitchell marner
nikolaj i know who the [ __ ] that is
leon dreissital of course he has 11
points edmonton toronto winnipeg
edmonton
look at that one two three four
the top four scorers in the league are
in canada and this year because of covid
only the canadian teams are only playing
each other so you got some of the top
scores so they might they either got the
best players up there they got some
shitty up in canada
uh mark storm bo horvit i don't know who
half of these [ __ ] guys are all right
we got a bruin in the top nine
i like it i like it um
what is that that's points
[ __ ] espn i swear to god points all
players
can we just say goals and assists all
right i'm going to the nhl
nhl.com nhl.com
that's offensively goals all right here
we go
my grandma max packer pack already
conor mcdavid mitch marnell where's
marshawn
where the [ __ ] is he all right he's got
a lot of assists all right go [ __ ]
yourselves
um oh there he is he's got four goals
five assists
there we go all right sorry
plowing ahead um oh my god i lost my
[ __ ] again last night
i don't lose it as bad as i used to but
i i'm losing it
i i feel like i'm starting to go back
with the frequency of it
um i had a bunch of [ __ ] i was supposed
to get that [ __ ] [ __ ] print
ink for my printer we have a [ __ ]
printer in my house people
i'm just bitching today we got a printer
in my [ __ ] house i never use it i so
don't use the [ __ ] thing that
whenever i have to i have to reintroduce
my computer to it i have to go online i
got to figure out how to re-sync it up
right
and i got to tell you every single
[ __ ] time i go to use it
i hit i you know i'm in the other room
you know my wife's always printing out
[ __ ] right so i [ __ ] hit print and i
hear the thing turn on
and then it invariably stops after a
page or two
and i get over there and either it's out
of ink
or it's out of paper right
so last night it it you know i go to hit
print
i'm in the other room i come walking in
there's like one piece of [ __ ] paper
left
okay so i'm like jesus [ __ ] christ
why won't she put more [ __ ] paper in
this thing
right boom i get it because what she
does is she just does the job and then
she moves forward she continues on
and leaves a trail of clues of what
she's been doing that's that's what she
does right so
my god [ __ ] it i open it up we got paper
good i put the paper in i hit resend
okay it's like 30 pages of [ __ ] right
it gets through about four and a half
five and then stops
and it needs ink and i'm like jesus
[ __ ] christ so i open up the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] sucking credenza thing and
i open it up in
in there is like five five
things of computer ink right
and i open it up the first one's color i
need black and white i open up the next
one it's color i open up the third one
it's color i open up the fourth one it's
color
there's one more left i'm like please
because you know the deal
you know the deal over that [ __ ] he's
[ __ ]
in p people you can't just buy the black
and white one because nobody needs the
color one
they make you [ __ ] buy both
okay here you go you got these [ __ ]
federal prosecutors they're gonna try to
prosecute somebody from murder that
didn't even go into the [ __ ] capital
building just held a [ __ ]
sign all right but these corporate [ __ ]
can do this [ __ ] as the oceans are all
[ __ ] polluted and it's [ __ ] 85
degrees out in december in la now what
the [ __ ] right
no these guys can these guys can get
away with [ __ ] murder
right [ __ ] murder so now
i just [ __ ]
when i opened the last one it was funny
i opened up the last one
and i see that it's color and i just go
oh what the
[ __ ] and then i hear way upstairs my
daughter who's already in bed i just
here go
yeah that's a bad word
i'm like you're right buddy i'm sorry
so i went upstairs you know trying to
control my breathing and i just
asked my wife about it and of course she
was just like oh i don't know i don't
know why there wasn't any paper in there
i go what about the ink she goes well it
was working fine when
when the last time i used it
and that's the best i'm ever gonna get
because i could then go okay well who
was the last one who changed the last
you know the ink and then looking back i
was like you know what it was probably
me
she was probably using and then i did it
i meant to made a mental note to buy the
[ __ ]
so you know it was probably my [ __ ]
fault anyways like you know i keep
bitching about how my [ __ ] tv doesn't
work
like it keeps getting [ __ ] up i we
finally figured out what the problem was
it was me
because when i would turn it on i would
hit menu
cable and then i would hit on i hit the
on button
so my wife was laughing she goes you
don't hit the on button i go well then
how do you turn it on
she goes she just hit menu and the
directv button
i go when you turn when do you hit the
on button she goes you don't
to turn it on you don't hit the on
button you know here we go first base
right again
she's like no you don't hit the on
button you just hit menu
and direct tv i go so when do i hit on
she goes never
so i'm like well then how do i shut it
off she goes you hit menu and you hit
off i go do i have to hit menu direct tv
off she goes no you just hit menu you
hit off
i go so to turn it off i hit off but to
turn it on i never
hit on she goes no and i was like well
what the [ __ ] is there an on button for
she goes i don't know
so with that hilarious conversation
i have been using my tv and it's come on
every single [ __ ] time
after i yelled at this [ __ ] tv i
yelled at this tv
like it was a person that wronged me
for 20 years and i just found out that's
the way i was yelling at this [ __ ] tv
you guys probably think i'm the biggest
[ __ ] [ __ ]
ever to live with and you'd be right so
i learned all of this [ __ ] in like the
last
week and it's been fantastic
because my son unfortunately last couple
nights has not been sleeping well
so i've been like up all night um
not up all night but just getting up
every two three hours which has been
you know it's you know it's not fun so
uh i have to sleep downstairs because
he's been sleeping in the bed with my
wife
and there's just not room for the three
of us you know
so i just go downstairs and i i leave
my phone on and um
i leave my phone on and because nobody's
going to text me after midnight you know
and
really at this point because no
comedians are working nobody even texts
me after 10.
so i just leave it on and then i just go
to sleep and then that awful ding sound
happens and then i sit up like try to
make that time to make the donuts i go
up and i change his diaper and
everything
um so anyway
the [ __ ] was i what was that leading to
oh yeah no so i've been downstairs and
i'm able to turn the tv
on i still have to have the lights on so
so it can
so the tv the smart tv realizes that
somebody's in the [ __ ] room at night
right
so i have to turn the lights on and then
the screen comes up then i shut it off
but then everything else
no i turn it on and then i shut off the
lights and everything
has been working finally
finally um so whatever so i was probably
wrong with the printer but i was
supposed to get the [ __ ] goddamn
printer into
ink today and i forgot to it's annoying
it's [ __ ] annoying i don't know
there's a staples out here in the valley
that i [ __ ]
used to go to all the time and uh
it just [ __ ] closed and
um i'm starting
i'm starting to realize like it's just
everything is just going to be online is
that how it is you never go out to a
store
i mean how many [ __ ] packages are you
gonna get you used to go out
you know just make you know you run your
errands you do the little [ __ ] loop
i swear to god man i don't know but you
know something old people always [ __ ]
about [ __ ] and i'm i'm no [ __ ]
different
let me do some reads here let me do a
little bit of advertising reads and i'll
tell you how much i
suck at flying a [ __ ] hell and i suck
today flying i just
we did some like hover autos which is
just sort of different muscle memory you
know
you roll down right
roll down and then it kicks to the right
so you go left pedal
pedal settle and then collective and
then we went to go do autos and then
it took me forever to get those things
then i got that down
and then we went to go do autos and i
didn't know what the [ __ ] i was doing
for like three of them and then i
figured it out
i was able in the end to finally um
kind of put all these pieces together
but i'm finding that i'm going to have
to solo more
just so like because i think when you
fly with somebody else you become like
dependent on them you just ah you know
he'll make the radio call or something
blah blah blah blah
i need to be doing that more so i really
kind of just
let the first half of my lesson go and i
just focused
uh on the way back was just like all
right i'm gonna stay at 1900 feet the
whole [ __ ] way
all right i'm not gonna go up or down
you know more i mean it was kind of
windy so
i'd go up and down 20 or 30 feet either
way but i kept it kind of where it was
at
we did a little bit of instrument
training flying to like vors and stuff
like that but uh
i just need to fly a little more
frequently and i think i'll have this
thing down because my quick stops and
everything got better
so anyway um all right romans
uh two reads romans a healthy life
includes a healthy sex
life but if you struggle with erectile
dysfunction
you may not feel like you you're your
best self if you just want to help with
erectile dysfunction roman connects you
with all a real u.s
licensed health care professional who
can be who can prescribe the medicine
you need
with roman you can get a free online
evaluation
oh look at it just sitting there and
ongoing care for erectile dysfunction
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home health care professionals with
uh will work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate
roman will ship you real medicine with
free two-day shipping
the whole process is straightforward
simple and discreet
getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com
and complete an online visit erectile
dysfunction
used to be tough to talk about uh but
now there's
roman complete an online visit today to
connect with the doctor and take care of
it dude if my dick didn't work that'd be
the first [ __ ] i'd be yelling that in
the waiting room
you got medicine for it uh just go to
getroman.com
burr to get 15 off your first order of
erectile dysfunction e.d
treatment and free online visit within
free two-day shipping
that's getroman.com for 15
off your first order of ed treatment get
roman.com
uh slash burr is that the website
yeah get roman g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n-dot-com
uh that's it all right okay
viomi uh viome
biome helps you take control of your
health
why do i keep saying like biome or biome
i don't know what the [ __ ] that is
either i'm looking this up i
am so sick of mispronouncing [ __ ] on
this thing
all right b-i-o-m-e pronunciation
[Music]
here we go ready biome okay i got it all
right i got it all right
volume hey you broke it jerry
you finally said it right all right
volume vayone helps you
take control of your healthcare so you
can improve your energy gut health and
boost your immune system health
how does it work test what your your
body slash cells actually doing
test what your body cells are actually
doing it just is actually doing
gives you complete nutrition plan
creates your custom supplement
i.e bill's personal one-a-day vitamin
with only the ingredients he needs
at his specific doses based on his test
cut out all the [ __ ] he doesn't need
or that could be hurting him it's the
perfect supplement i have to [ __ ] do
this
this seems like the easiest way to stay
in shape you know exactly
what your body reacts to positively and
what exactly what it doesn't
uh viome has partnered with the mayo
clinic mayo like mayonnaise mayo clinic
united health like the airlines united
health and kaiser
like kaiser sosa so say a so-so
and is used by olympic gold medalists
and elite professional athletes are you
saying that olympic gold medalist is not
an elite professional athlete
uh biome will tell you how specific
foods affect you
you may be eating too much or not eating
enough of what your body needs
imagine if you did the test and it said
you know what you need to eat more ice
cream
ah [ __ ] rules biomes phone
application lets you get these answers
on demand
questions about food just check the app
go to vyom.com to get your unique
insights for better health and wellness
use the promo code bird to save 55
on your first planned purchase this is
the best discount anywhere
they're giving it to us special for bill
you guys got to do it
you got to do it get in the best shape
of your life in 2021
get vaccinated and all of that crap hit
the ground running
with your abs and your your [ __ ]
lungs that are that are not
there to covet free how about that
um
you know i think that's the last thing i
haven't seen that i thought was bad for
me that people said was good
you know i like all of a sudden out of
nowhere people started like
pouring melted butter into their coffee
i think rogan was telling me about that
i was like
butter isn't that bad no it was a lie
you know so that's kind of cool who
doesn't like butter i [ __ ] love
butter
i [ __ ] love it um
i think that's the last thing that i
haven't seen like you know the atkins
diet all of a sudden people sitting
there with handfuls of bacon you just
look at him like
are you sure about that use much protein
vegetables as i like as long as i don't
have bread i can eat all this greasy
bacon and i'll be fine
and you just sit there looking at him
like i don't think that's right
but i'm not a nutritionist so good on
you right
the next diet they gotta do the dairy
industry has to figure out a way
where they can fudge the numbers and lie
to people
and tell them that ice cream is gonna
get him abs
now there is a [ __ ] you know as long as
you only eat celery sticks
dude i'm on the rocky road celery stick
diet
i have a big bowl of ice cream to start
my day and in between i eat celery
sticks
and then i have ice cream sundae for
lunch then i have some more celery
and then i have a banana split for
dinner and i go to bed
i am so [ __ ] i have wild dreams but i
am so [ __ ] happy
it's it's like it's my birthday three
times a day
what is your guys idea heaven
my idea of heaven is i can get i just
want to get
[ __ ] hammered and smoke cigars
and eat bad food and not be a fat angel
but then again you could be a fat angel
because it's heaven
no one would make funny and you could
still have a supermodel [ __ ]
angel blowing you because it's heaven
right isn't heaven
your idea what heaven is
you could ride a [ __ ] motorcycle
never wipe out or if you did you
wouldn't die because you're
already dead but you wouldn't wipe out
it's heaven
it's [ __ ] hilarious my idea going to
heaven is just [ __ ] getting hammered and
have materialistic things
um
it's [ __ ] hilarious do people go to a
minimalist house to trick or treat i
mean you got to be thinking like
i mean that could go either way it's
like this guy's either going to give me
one
eminem or he's just going to [ __ ]
give me a bag of m
ms in his stereo cause he has no [ __ ]
room for it
[Music]
he's a minimalist he wants to get it out
of the house
all right i'm gonna go watch the bruins
everybody um
sorry if i was a little grumpy today i
just uh haven't gotten a lot of sleep
this week i'm hoping my little champ i
love him to death you know
he just he when i tell you a kid just
smiles with his whole face
and um he's like crawling
like 90 miles an hour now so now he's
like playing with my daughter
crawled up her on top of her when they
were on the bed and she was like
laughing he like likes the rough house
already he's all boy man it's gonna be
great
and um
i'm going to have so much fun with them
which is why i need to use
go to that biome and figure out what's
good for me so i can stay in shape so i
can keep up with them
that's my goal all right okay that's the
podcast thank you guys for listening
please enjoy the music picked out by the
great andrew themless
we will have a um
a bonus episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast
after the music and uh
have a great football this weekend
maybe watch a little bit of hoop or some
hockey february is coming up moto gp is
coming
f1 is coming a lot of great stuff is on
the way
on the horizon i wanna you know when i
was flying
the heli today uh i saw
a bunch of people in line to get
vaccinated
someplace which was which was cool so
people are out there doing
it um oh my god
can you dare to think of it all going
back to normal
how [ __ ] fun would that be
just sitting in traffic again i don't
mind sitting in traffic now because i
just listen to french lessons
you know i know i always sound like i'm
out of my [ __ ] mind but i think this
one was particularly i was a little
sideways on this one sorry lack of sleep
i apologize god bless all you
go [ __ ] yourselves have a great weekend
you [ __ ] and i'll talk to you monday
what's going on it's bill burr and it's
the monday morning podcast for
monday january 28
2013 uh i apologize for it being uh
this late and i'm going to pause for all
the truly angry people out there
whatever where you to [ __ ] um
let them get that out of their system
you know
one of the key things you got to figure
out in life is who you're really mad at
you know are you really mad at me you
never met me
i haven't done nothing to you um
i apologize i had a crazy frigging
weekend now last i talked to use
unless you're new to the podcast and if
you're new welcome
huh look at me i'd say i'm borderline
jovial at this point
welcome to the monday morning podcast um
last i spoke with you i was on my way to
hawaii
and i was going to go to the pro bowl
then initially i was going to stay there
for a week but uh
i ended up getting some acting work
which is great so i had to cut it short
and tell the lovely nia that i couldn't
take it to hawaii i'll have to do it
next time and basically i was going to
go out there
i was going to do my show at the
republic and then i was going to go to
the pro bowl the next day
you know then go look at a volcano
whatever the [ __ ] i was going to do when
i was going to fly back but at least i
was going to do that and
um i ended up uh getting another acting
gig
on monday and i know what you're
thinking jesus bill
hey you're acting all over the place
you know and you know what no i'm not
no i'm not
i'm not it's just this business
knows it it knows when you when you're
planning to do something fun
you know i don't have any fun plans next
month
no vacations not water skiing i'm not
taking that that uh
that needlepoint class that i've had my
eye on
i don't have any fun plans next month
and you know what i have for acting
worth
i got [ __ ] i got nothing
this [ __ ] goddamn business it saw it
felt it
felt it in the universe oh look at billy
redface
oh freckleface himself he's gonna go to
the islands go to a game have a good
time hey go [ __ ] yourself there's a
couple acting gigs
you go out there you do your stand-up
gig all right you go to bed you get on a
plane you [ __ ] come right back
nothing for you that's what i did this
weekend
i worked friday night saturday i got on
a [ __ ] plane by myself
all right and i'm sitting there you know
when you fly to hawaii
i've never done this before they have
like on the monitors they're playing the
music they already got the music going
right whatever the [ __ ] they kept
playing that [ __ ]
you already feel like you're in hawaii
and i'm sitting there like an [ __ ]
i'm looking around everybody's got their
wife or their girlfriend you know
or whatever their fantasy football
[ __ ] [ __ ] boyfriend whatever the
[ __ ] they got whatever the hell it is
when guys all going on vacation and
they're not in their 20s
whatever the [ __ ] that's called that
we're sick of a [ __ ] wives vacation i
don't know what it is
and i'm sitting there like an [ __ ]
right
so i fly out there crack it dawn
fly out there and uh
i can't even remember the [ __ ]
weekend
yeah nia didn't give me a ride so it
must have been really early we kind of
have this deal if it's
too early i i just jump in a cab so i
took a cab
to the airport got on the [ __ ] plane
flew out there landed and you know
because i wasn't bringing my girls just
like [ __ ] it i'll stay whatever i'll
stay at the cheapest place
out of the three that were so given to
me right so and i show up to this
[ __ ] place
it's like i i show up i'm the only guy
like
under the age of like 78 there it's just
a bunch of [ __ ] old people
and there's an ihop built into the place
and there's like a [ __ ] homeless guy
it just i felt like i was staying
in like the port authority section of
hawaii
and what makes it worse is i got there
12 noon and my room wasn't ready until
3. so now i'm sitting there like this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and i'm like adamant i'm not going to
the ihop they have those on the mainland
i want to do some island [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] 12 hours that i'm gonna be here
and there was a diner on the corner
and i went there and i i'm standing
there's like [ __ ] 12 people in line i
mean you gotta be [ __ ] me
right this is just a stupid touristy
place
there's [ __ ] candy wrappers on the
ground before i even go in there
there's the rhesus rapper on one side
there's the cup from the reese's cup
like somebody just [ __ ] just ripped
it open
like just it was such force the rhesus
cup went up in the air he fired both
[ __ ] parts of the package part and
port and starboard
and then just gulped it down as he ran
out not paying for it or whatever
looked like there was some somebody got
mugged who had some candy
you know so i'm sitting there going this
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] hole but i don't have
a car and i'm like [ __ ] it i'm going to
stay right
so i go there and i ordered this thing
uh that evidently was a hawaiian dish
and just turned out to be a burger patty
with some gravy and some eggs
and i'm sitting there eating it by
myself mind you i can't go to the pro
bowl now because i have to fly right the
[ __ ] back
and uh i'm sitting there and also this
guy taps me on
on my shoulder and i look over and he
goes hey excuse me he goes what are you
eating
that looks delicious i look at the guy
and i'm like i know this [ __ ] guy
who was this guy he looked like a mix
between
hulk hogan and triple h so i kept
thinking is this guy a [ __ ] wrestler
and then i i told him i don't want the
name of the dishes but just say
hamburger patty with eggs and
and gravy and they'll get it too and he
laughed and goes hey thanks and he
walked away
and i sat there for five minutes and i
was like [ __ ]
that was kevin green former pittsburgh
steeler i swear to god i'm 90 percent
sure
it was him so that was the one cool
thing that happened to me
somebody who i think was kevin green
asked me what i was eating i told him i
didn't know what the name of it was he
laughed and he left
and then i ate that [ __ ] and they go do
you want dessert it's like no i don't
want dessert but i still have two hours
and 15 minutes to kill
before my [ __ ] room's ready so bring
it on lady
what do you got what do you got you got
some hooky loud [ __ ]
hookah [ __ ] ice cream because i want
it
i want to do something hawaiian because
i'm leaving in [ __ ] 12 hours right
so they got this hawaiian fried ice
cream
and immediately i'm thinking well isn't
that just what you know mexicans do that
right this
is the same [ __ ] so what i never had
fried ice cream before so
yeah let me get the fried ice cream [ __ ]
it and i'm sitting there and i'm sitting
there
and this old lady's looking like this
chick look like she looked like you know
like whenever
they interview people who are still
alive that are in like
alfred hitchcock movies like that chick
from the birds or maybe the chick from
psycho that's what she looked like but
like
her age now she's sitting there you know
she's
you know an old redhead and i'm like is
that what i'm going to look like except
for like the male version
this is what i'm thinking about in
paradise you know
paradise sitting in some [ __ ] [ __ ]
diner this is all stuff they don't show
you on the brochure by the way sitting
in some [ __ ] [ __ ] diner
and uh so
by the way the food was delicious i
gotta tell you this it was delicious
but it was a dump um
so that's like 15 minutes go by i'm like
it's [ __ ] ice cream
what are you doing just scoop it out of
the thing and i'm like are they really
frying this how do you fry it without
melting it
this is the dumbest podcast ever so they
finally bring it over it's this big
goop of [ __ ] [ __ ] and it's just
surrounded by this moat of whipped cream
you know and i ate the whole [ __ ]
thing out of sheer but like trying to
kill time
it's probably like 3 000 calories plus i
had a burger with gravy
gravy on it with two eggs over easy
all of it delicious all of it a
wonderful thing to eat
if you're [ __ ] 14 years old but if
you're 44
it's not a good scene so anyways i
finally get into the uh
the hotel and we have a package for you
look at the packages
package i look at the package and it's
the [ __ ] pro bowl tickets that i'm
not going to and i hand them over to my
buddy
uh uh [ __ ] rose bowl legend jason
lawhead he takes them out they're like
glowing like that [ __ ] in pulp fiction
and i'm like and i'm in my head i'm like
dude you got to put those things away
i didn't say it i was like oh yeah
that's great man have a great time i
heard their great seats you
[ __ ] cook um
so whatever oh i forgot this part
i come walking out of the the diner
and that homeless guy i saw sitting
there who looked like kenny rogers if he
never got the plastic surgery and like
lived outside
since the nixon administration right
he's sitting there and when i come out
there's a security guard there you know
no gun no authority he's just sent out
there
baby face he's like [ __ ] 21 years old
and i could see the
his body language like ah jesus christ
right and all i hear is the homeless guy
like no
i'm not leaving send me to jail i'm not
cause i don't want to
and you see the kid like dude i really
don't want to you think i want to do
this job somebody sent me out here
and i'm just and i just start [ __ ]
laughing to myself
because i for some reason i didn't think
i was good you know
i'm going to hawaii i feel like i'm
going to paradise there's not going to
be homeless people here it's [ __ ]
paradise right and and it was the same
[ __ ]
the same [ __ ] i was in air in an area
i felt like i was going to get mugged i
found out later that there's a bunch of
hookers in that area i was like we talk
about there's a bunch of uh
people with kids like no no at night at
night they all come out and i was just
like
you know how did they get out there you
know how many
dicks did they suck to get out there and
like
how many [ __ ] uh i don't know hey
spared some change how long were you
begging
somebody try to tell me that cities put
their homeless guys on planes and fly
them out there
like they said they called the rainbow
project and i didn't believe that for a
[ __ ] second
and i didn't give a [ __ ] if you send me
documented proof there's no [ __ ] way
you get a crazy homeless guy and all his
funk on a [ __ ] plane
you know they can still refuse your
service there's no way he's coming on
there
with his [ __ ] horrific feet
and elbows and all that you know there's
no way
there's no way and plus the guy's gonna
[ __ ] have a seizure by the time he
gets there from alcohol withdrawal
you know those amstels they sell on the
plane aren't going to help them
but you know what i think it is you know
i think it's just being around the beach
like a beach bum there's something about
being around the beach like yeah
i'll get to it tomorrow you know
ah yeah did i did i pay rent i can't
remember nixon are you homeless you got
you know give a [ __ ]
weather's nice sleep under a palm tree
you know
i don't i wasn't even there long enough
so i did my show
at this place the republic republic and
it was the [ __ ]
crowd was [ __ ] awesome sold out thank
you to everybody who came out
i'm definitely coming back it was some
of the best energy
i've had at a show since i can remember
people were so
psyched that somebody from the mainland
fl flew his pasty ass
all the way out there i i ran into one
guy he like flew over from another
island
um it was like it was locals it wasn't
tourists
and i found the couple of times i've
performed on islands
people who live on islands are [ __ ]
cool as hell
you know i did a gig on nantucket uh
last year you know and i met up you know
fishermen and people who were there
year-round
through all the weather and all that
[ __ ] it's just uh they're good people
man so i had a great time there
uh finished my show you know
hoard myself out sold the dvd smiling
and waving i had two beers went back to
the hotel
slept for four and a half five hours got
on a [ __ ] plane and flew right back
oh wait wait i bought a magnet
to prove like technically i can't even
say i was there
because i didn't do anything i did walk
down to the beach for half a second
and took a picture of myself which
evidently is called a selfie
i learned that on chelsea peretti's
twitter it's called the selfie
i took one of those with a mountain in
the background sort of with a bunch of
buildings
and uh but you know the upside was uh
it sold out the crowd was awesome i'm
definitely going to come back
and i think that there is going to be
another pro bowl because uh
i guess the game was was you know a
bunch of scoring they were sort of
hitting
and i think the nfl was just sort of
threatening the players like hey
quit [ __ ] dogging the entire game
because it's an embarrassment to the
league
you know how about a mild concussion can
you give that up for the league
just so we can keep this thing going you
know so it isn't a total [ __ ]
embarrassment but
whatever i had a great time when i was
out there the uh
i don't know what the [ __ ] i landed at
12 i left the next morning at
five what is that 17 hours
oh geez um
yeah then i flew back i did a [ __ ]
acting gig they put some
glued some [ __ ] to my face did that this
morning and then i flew
[ __ ] back here and now i'm doing my
podcast
and uh neo was giving me [ __ ] you're
gonna do the podcast now
you know how they do that like she i
don't know women are great they just
want to hang out
if you would if you just do it with them
like she actually there's actually a
reality show that she's watching right
now that i that i can watch
because it's a bunch of i don't know
you know it's a bunch of morons but
they're morons that i can relate to
um all right what are we doing here i
gotta make sure i do the [ __ ]
advertising i kind of screwed this up
last week
um all right everybody a little bit of
advertising here on the monday morning
podcast
uh legal zoom everybody uh you know what
you need to accomplish
at the start of the new year you need to
think about legal protection for your
family and business but where do you
turn for
affordable legal solutions you can trust
legalzoom.com
these guys are great these guys
basically take care all that pain in the
butt stuff that you know you should be
doing
but you put off you know you can get it
all done at legalzoom.com and it won't
cost you a fortune
they have an a rating from the better
business bureau legalzoom has been
helping families and businesses get
personalized legal protection for the
past 12 years
whether you need to incorporate your
business form an
llc or protect your family with a will
or a living trust
all uh legal zoom documents are state
specific
and their step-by-step process
makes it simple um yet for some reason i
can't read the copy because i'm a [ __ ]
uh and with legal zoom you can you can
even access an extensive network of
legal plan
attorneys for guidance so basically you
can take care of all of that
they got a step-by-step process if i can
say it
to walk you through it and uh if you
actually any have any problems they have
attorneys that will give you guidance uh
legalzoom is not a law firm
you can get self-help service at your
specific direction
or you can speak to a legal plan
attorney to get your questions
answers and get ongoing advice uh before
another year passes
uh passes you by cross a couple things
off your new year's checklist today at
legalzoom.com and save a pile of money
while doing it enter bur
burr in the referral box
at checkout for even more savings at
legalzoom.com i highly recommend that
everybody
um do not wait that's the kind of thing
that you put off and then something
horrific happens and you didn't do it
and people are left with their pockets
turned inside out please don't do that i
don't wish that on anybody
you know and i know it's a pain in the
butt and legalzoom.com makes it easy all
right there you go there's a
little advertising a little advice uh
real quick uh what do we got now
stamps.com the old favorites here uh
if you haven't heard yet postage rates
have changed again you know what that
means the post office will
be even more crowded than usual that's
why you need stamps.com stamps.com
everybody if you never want to go to the
post office again
yet be able to do everything that you
want to do at the post office
right from your own home um you can do
anything there you can print uh
legal postage you can do it right from
your desk buy and print official u.s
postage
for any letter or package using your own
computer or printer and stamps.com
always update the postage rates for you
automatically so you don't have to think
about it you don't have to
go back down to the post office and get
the two cent stamp and stick it on
or forget be out of the loop and have
that important bill come back to you
they handle all of it stamp stamps.com
always updates the postage rates
you'll never have to go to the post
office again i use stamps.com
for the last uh a little over a year
i've been sending my dvds to all my uh
all my uh my
my whatever the hell i'm trying to say
all my stand-up events
good god almighty i'm sorry i flew on
three planes in the last two days
um right now use my last name bur burr
for this special offer no risk trial
plus 110
bonus offer offer includes a digital
scale and up to 55 dollars free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in burr b-u-r-r
that's stamps.com and enter bur
okey-dokey uh back to the podcast here
um all right so what's coming up this
you know what's coming up this week
[ __ ] super bowl dude who do you like
this is what i'm doing for the super
bowl all right
i have to work the day of the super bowl
believe it or not
all right old twinkle toes is finishing
up an acting gig here and speaking of
acting gigs
um i have a movie coming out or there's
a movie coming out that i'm in
it's not my movie it's a movie i'm happy
to be in it's called stand up guys comes
out february 1st
all right stars al pacino christopher
walken and alan arkin
huh and oh billy redface is walking by
in the background for a couple of scenes
do not blink
you will miss me but you remember back
in april of last year
when the podcast was late and everybody
was giving me a ton of [ __ ] about it
and i said you wait in eight [ __ ]
months i'm gonna have the greatest
excuse ever i was late that day
because i was in a scene with uh al
pacino and christopher walken all right
so go [ __ ] yourself that's why it was
late
how do you like that how do you like
them apples
huh i'm a boston guy can i say that i
grew up in the suburbs
you can only say that if you're from
southie
anyways um i'll be working on the day of
the super bowl
but i don't give a [ __ ] because uh
in my limited wisdom i think i've i've
figured out
how to watch the super bowl all right
not only do you watch it by yourself
okay it's the most important game of the
year it's for the championship
these [ __ ] guys are playing a game
where
they're gonna die i hope all the rugby
people are paying attention to the level
of concussions
right there leading with your shoulders
and no pads not saying you're not tough
okay i think this finally
proves that american football is
the most psycho [ __ ] sport there is
not psycho sport but you know what i
mean
i wouldn't even say it's tougher than
rugby both sports are tough but like
the whole thing that english people and
they they always say that oh they got
helmets on their [ __ ] [ __ ]
all the helmet does is make you think
that you're protected
and you use it as a weapon but your
[ __ ] brains in there in the [ __ ]
water and it's slamming all over your
head
and then when you're 40 you shoot
yourself in the chest
you know so scientists can [ __ ] look
at your brain and figure what's going on
in there
do rugby people do that at 40 i don't
think you do
i think you're still running around out
on the pitch with the [ __ ] masking
tape around your ears
as far as my research goes sorry every
once in a while i gotta wake those [ __ ]
up
um so anyways this is how i'm going to
watch
the super bowl you got to watch it by
yourself
you got to get away from the [ __ ] the
the
the all the broads that come over
including the [ __ ] guy broads
you know the ones who don't watch
football and they just show up for the
dip and they're
they're there with the [ __ ] chicks
they're trying to get laid in your
[ __ ] house it's basically what
they're doing
they talk during the game and they shut
up during the commercial and then when
the game comes back on they're like i
didn't like that one
i thought that was good how much do you
think that cost
right and meanwhile you can't even watch
the [ __ ] game and then every [ __ ]
year
they gotta have some wailing [ __ ] or
some
aging [ __ ] rock star with hair plugs
come out there for one last [ __ ]
swing at glory so this is what you do
and people invite you to the shoe hey
what are you doing for the super bowl
ah you know what i'm um i'm going
i got this thing i gotta do uh yeah i
gotta go out in the woods
come up with something or just just
you know what why do you gotta lie i'm
watching it by myself
why are you going to do that because i
want to watch the game
that's why all right so now you've
eliminated all the [ __ ]
that are that that are going to be in
your living room
now that's stage one of the [ __ ] removal
stage two is to get rid of the [ __ ] you
don't want to see
that are on the television and this is
the most important part
you record the [ __ ] game i know a lot
of people already do this [ __ ] but
there's people who don't
okay so just bear with me you record the
[ __ ] game
you shut off your [ __ ] cell phone you
don't answer your phone you don't go on
your computer
all right and you just as as
the whole rest of the world is watching
somebody lip sync some pre-recorded
[ __ ]
brain whatever the [ __ ] they do right
in the [ __ ] just go right over the
[ __ ] top
you know what do you do downstairs
spackle on a wall
wait for that red that pink spackle to
turn white so you can sand that [ __ ]
down
right put a little goddamn paint on it
nobody knows
nobody knows from last year when you
punch the wall because that [ __ ]
douche wouldn't shut up during the game
and he was double dipping you [ __ ]
put your hand through the wall fix that
thing patch that hole in the wall
as everybody is watching huey lewis in
the news wham
try to [ __ ] kick off the game whoever
the [ __ ] they got this year
right they got beyonce's gonna sing
or whatever the hell she's gonna do the
whole halftime she shouldn't be there
unless she's watching the why is she out
there what's she going to you know out
there a little glitter hot pants
you know i don't want to see that [ __ ]
so what you do is you just let the game
go
let it go for a good i don't know 90
minutes two hours
then you sit down like you control the
universe
like you're jesus walking on the water
except you're sitting in your [ __ ]
chair
and you turn that [ __ ] on and you hit
fast forward one
two three four and you watch all the
talking heads and then you you [ __ ]
you're watching fast motion
adam and the answer whoever the [ __ ]
they have opening up
maybe metallica singing a [ __ ] tom
petty song maybe tom petty's there with
him and that [ __ ] uh
uh what the hell's his name there lou
reed maybe he's out there singing it who
the [ __ ] knows that seems to be the
thing you have the old people first
then you get some young hottie during
halftime
sitting there with the tits hanging out
doesn't know what you do that's america
um you fast forward to all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the beginning
and you just get right to the kickoff
you just watch the game
that's your leisure that's your [ __ ]
leisure and then you know what happens
after the first half
and they start wheeling that big dumb
[ __ ] stage out there
and every douchebag whoever had a
[ __ ] dream of dancing is [ __ ] you
just taking up a whole football field of
[ __ ]
singers and dancers the most unfootball
[ __ ] thing you could possibly have
you know everybody
who talked during the first half they're
all shutting up they're sitting there on
their [ __ ] knees two feet from your
[ __ ]
breathing on your flat screen you know
like it's the beginning of the mickey
mouse club and they got their [ __ ]
ears on
you fast forward through all of that
[ __ ]
and you just go right in and then you
know what happens is you never lose
the flow of the game now
before you know what why don't you
invite a couple of people over who want
to do it that way
people who want to shut the [ __ ] up real
fast
and i suggest this do you want to sound
intelligent to the people that you're
going to watch the game with i highly
recommend buying the sports illustrated
this week that has both
of the har brother harbaugh brothers
however the [ __ ] you say their names
on the cover um both phenomenal coaches
obviously they're there in the super
bowl god damn it they both of them
if their teams didn't [ __ ] up i know
it's a big if
49ers didn't drop three [ __ ] punts or
whatever the hell it did last year
and uh you know what the ravens did what
they missed a [ __ ] extra point or
something i came it was like a
chip shot um that would have been back
to back years with them
who knows they want they both would have
gone and then they would have partied
too much and then they would have sucked
this year that's what happens
but whatever um anyways so they got this
great article
where they they break down the game at a
level that i wish
i could like i knew more of
um they got this thing in there remember
remember when uh what the [ __ ] his name
i was gonna say hammerlick
been watching too much [ __ ] hockey
what's the name of the uh
cam cameron the [ __ ] the name of the
quarterback
kaepernick what's his name chris
kaepernick
chip kaepernick uh creepy kaepernick
whatever the [ __ ] his name is the guy's
the [ __ ]
you know when he was running wild like
[ __ ] hulk hogan against the uh green
bay packers
basically he was uh they would they were
breaking down that play
trying to see if they would be able to
run it and they
it's called the zone read and they run
it out of the the pistol alignment how
cool is that
which is basically the shotgun formation
but you're closer to the center so they
call it the pistol alignment you got a
tailback right behind you and this is
what happens
you hike the ball quarterback turns
around he puts the ball
right in the [ __ ] breadbasket at the
tailback
and right there he does his own read
which basically means he looks at that
defensive end of the linebacker who's
supposed to seal off the edge
and he basically does a quick read if
the [ __ ] guy
holds his ground he just hands them he
continues handing the ball off
to the [ __ ] tailback but if the
[ __ ] guy
on the end bites on it starts to pinch
in you pull it back and you [ __ ] run
around
you run around the side there you go
that's called a zone read from the
pistol alignment and the point where
you're holding the ball
almost giving it to tailback but not
really but maybe you're gonna that's
called the mesh point
i wish i knew this [ __ ] i really did but
they have like 10 pages on this [ __ ]
talking about the ravens defense their
running game
uh was absolutely fascinating so much
better
than watching uh espn and watching herm
edwards screaming
or that guy with the hair and the cold
pizza yelling you know you know he
always sucked in gym class he wreaks of
it
reeks of it he looks like he's good at
like rich white guy sports
like uh i'd say polo but he's so [ __ ]
short he'd probably fall off the horse
trying to hit that ball
i think maybe a badminton there you go
badminton maybe he's good at badminton
but uh this is like everything you want
to know without the screaming and
yelling and i'm really being a nerd
right now because i'm basically saying
the book is better than the movie but uh
i highly recommend
reading that [ __ ] and then watching the
game by yourself and seeing if you can
pick out the pistol alignment
the zone reading the pistol alignment
you know
i don't know that type of [ __ ] excites
me don't you want to know what the cover
2 is
for once in your life don't you wish you
could watch football these [ __ ]
[ __ ] playing fantasy football and
[ __ ] with their faces two inches from
the goddamn screen memorizing stats
wouldn't you want to be up in the stands
being able to see what each team is
doing and how teams are adjusting
like last week it was like or two weeks
ago when the 49ers were obviously they
were down like 14 nothing or something
crazy and all of a sudden it just
stopped and they came back and
everybody's going kaepernick kaepernick
i'm reading this [ __ ] article and the
uh one of the offensive coordinators
or the 49ers like now you know after you
know about a quarter
quarter and a half we kind of saw what
they were doing and then we adjusted to
it
and you're like oh that's what happened
i just thought the momentum changed
magic like i i watch it at such a i'm a
ball watcher i hate it i hate that i am
i wish i could sit up in the stands and
be like oh it's a [ __ ] you know
i don't know any other defense other
than cover two i love him what's his
face
i actually hate it when gruden starts
talking about the defenses and stuff
they got hey girls in the books
and they they start throwing out this
terminology it's like why don't you
[ __ ] tell me what it means
you know i don't know bill why don't you
utilize the internet and [ __ ] look it
up i'm sure there's a youtube video
about it okay you got me
so anyways that's how i'm watching the
uh that's how i'm watching the super
bowl
thoughts anyone anybody is this even
remotely [ __ ] interesting i don't i
don't you know
whatever you know my policy i always
tape in the morning
i never tape on days when i flew on a
[ __ ] plane but i had no choice
because i had to fly today
all right um all right last piece of
advertising for this week e-voice
everybody
uh e-voice is what busy professionals
use to save time
and to work smarter e-voice converts all
your voicemails to text and sends it
directly to your cell phone
no more interrupting your day to check
your voicemail or waiting till after a
meeting to find out what's going on
uh with e-voice your calls will always
be rooted to you no matter where you are
e-voice also comes with your own
conference line for up to 94
participants
on a single call you could have
literally ended
the nhl lockout with 94 participants
that's got to be every owner
plus uh the three guys on their top
lines right
um it all starts for less than ten
dollars per month but right now they
have a special offer for our
uh for my podcast listeners you can get
evoice free for six months with no
obligation
for your free six-month trial please go
to www.evoice.com
and enter the promo code bill all right
perfect if you're trying to start up a
business it's only 10 bucks a month you
should pay that anyways and they're
giving it to you for six months you have
no excuse
go there now please all right
back to the podcast here uh what else
did i want to talk about oh i saw a good
documentary this week
this is more me reminiscing about my
week
sort of a verbal diary audio diary
um i saw this uh
new documentary on ginger baker
which is funny i used to listen to when
i was growing up ginger baker and i
thought it was just a nickname this is
before
ginger that term jumped the ocean and
came over here
uh from ireland scotland and england
he was a redheaded dude gingerbreaker
whatever so the name of this podca
podcast the aim of this uh documentary
is beware of mr baker
and i don't care if you play drums or
not there's no way
you're not going to enjoy this this
guy's one of the most interesting human
beings i've ever seen in my life
you guys think i'm a crabby old [ __ ]
man you got to see this guy
and he trashes john bonham
he trashes him and i'm gonna say what he
says here in about five seconds so
fast forward if you don't want me to
ruin it but uh for those of you who
don't play drums nobody trashes john
bonham unless you're just some troll
trying to piss people off on the
internet it's like
he's he's the [ __ ] king as far as
rock drummers go the guy's the king it's
you know
there's definitely the who's better
bottom or pert and they argue but nobody
ever says that bonham sucks
if you're just being a douche but ginger
baker actually
he said they asked him what he thought
about john bonham
and i guess people trash around the
internet because there's so many [ __ ]
there but anytime you ever ask a drummer
a rock drummer about john bonap they all
just in hush tones
speak of the power his swing his
feel his subtlety his originality
his the triplets the single bass drum
the whole [ __ ] thing
and ginger baker said john bonham
couldn't swing a sack of [ __ ]
it was one of the [ __ ] my jaw was
almost on the ground
i couldn't [ __ ] believe it and i just
burst it out laughing
i have never to hear somebody who's
considered a god just
dismissed like that and then even like
clapton he didn't [ __ ] on bona but like
clapton they were like you know
how do you compare bottom to ginger
baker and he was just like oh no
no he's like you know it's not even a
basically it's not even a contest
ginger baker was a fully formed musician
a composer and and all this type of
stuff
i don't know it just for me i don't like
i mean i've actually looked at photos
online and considered
blo having them blown up and hanging
them in my house of john bonham that's
like what i think of them
and just to hear somebody just you know
basic he's like my
lance armstrong like you know something
like from
my lance armstrong moment you know those
people got all disappointed like what do
i tell my kids
my lance armstrong moment would be if i
found out that
in the studio he actually played a
double pedal
or a double bass drum now i know a lot
of you guys are going to show that
picture of him with the double bass drum
set up
i know the story behind that that was
all when he first got the kit
uh when what's his face hooked him up
with that this is so [ __ ] inside at
this point
you'd have to be a drummer too even like
any of this carmen apathy
carmine apathy or a pc i've had like 58
different pronunciations of their last
name he had a deal with ludwig and i
think
bonham initially was playing
slingerlands
and carmine got him in with ludwig and
he got the same setup that carmine had
so he had the double bass and he brought
it to like one rehearsal
and the other guys in the band just kept
taking the other bass drum out
just going you don't need it it's
cluttering up everything
um i really can't imagine him playing a
double bass drum set he would have
[ __ ]
drowned out the whole goddamn band um
but whatever and anybody thinks he
doesn't have a fast foot just watch him
at royal albert hall in 1970 then you
can go [ __ ] yourself
but evidently ginger baker says he he
couldn't swing a sack of [ __ ] which just
killed me um if you just want to see a
[ __ ] angry redhead
play in drums because i haven't made any
drum videos yet
[Laughter]
this is the guy this is the real deal um
it's called uh
beware of mr baker um underrated
listening to ginger baker for a [ __ ]
hour and a half it was awesome and then
i actually watched
some of the the comeback shows that they
had the one at royal albert hall and he
was [ __ ] unbelievable
drums just sounded amazing an incredible
player
uh but that's just the tip of the
iceberg it's just how he lives his life
going broke and just moving on from
relationships
um really an amazing documentary so
anyways with that let's get to some of
your questions here i feel like i've
been running my mouth here for [ __ ]
almost 40 minutes here
um bill heard you love drinking hey man
heard you love to drink and i agree
drinking's great
but i haven't been handling my liquor
too well of late
i've been getting blackout drunk every
night for a while now except for a week
what did you blacked out drunk when you
wrote this
i've been get i've been getting blackout
drunk every night for a while now
except for a week maybe a month here and
there okay there we go that was on me
sorry
what i want to remember things that have
actually happened and not just
night terrors any tips on drinking
semi-responsible
um i really would like to continue to
use it as a social lubricant
in overall good time liquid thanks for
the free rant
rants uh you're welcome um
i've been getting blackout drunk every
night for a while now ah dude you sound
like uh i i'm
i love to drink but i don't get blackout
drunk
i get just to the point where i say
something i wish i didn't say
and i don't do it every night um getting
blackout drunk every night um it depends
on your age
i mean if you're like i don't know 17 18
and you just discovered alcohol and
you're [ __ ] you know
drinking the way you [ __ ] 90 miles an
hour
um that's
only semi scary even that's scary
but uh yeah dude blackout drunk is some
serious [ __ ] um i don't know
i would talk to somebody uh
i don't know what i would do if i was
getting blackout drunk every [ __ ]
night i think i would quit for a while
well i get to a point where i just
embarrass myself too much and then i
just need to like back off
um i've been really big on beer lately i
go back and forth between scotch and
beer and i got into beer
and i got into the whole fancy [ __ ]
beers now i'm back to beer that i
like my dad drank and my friend's dad's
drank
when i was a kid so it was basically
beer that we stole
so every once in a while go back to
beers i drank in high school and i drink
them and it's this weird sort of like
you know i don't know when i taste it i
just think about
i always picture you know just drinking
in the woods
the cops do the cops are coming um
so yeah that would be that would be my
uh
look if you're not an alcoholic i would
just monitor your drinking but if you're
getting blackout drunk every night you
might have a problem
so i wouldn't want to tell you how to
drink semi-responsibly because if you're
an alcoholic you're not going to um
so i would explore a little more your
level of addiction
and when you figure that out i would
then
act accordingly and if you figure out
that you're an alcoholic i would
try and quit drinking as soon as
possible because it will ruin your life
um believe me
i said something [ __ ] horrible this
weekend after i did my shows it was only
after like two beers
i'm going to try to figure out how to
tell this story without outing anybody
in it
i'm sitting there i'm having drinks and
these two girls come up
yeah you're funny but hey thanks a lot
how long you staying out here uh i got
to leave in five hours what are you a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes i
am that type of [ __ ] and so they pointed
this girl she's like the girl next door
going hey you know what she does
what do you think she does and i was
this and usually i can get a read i just
couldn't get a read on this girl
i don't know what she did she looked
like she would just work in customer
service but there was something
different about her
but it was because she looked like that
i couldn't uh she just looked like she
just get a regular job
you know get married become a mom one of
those people
they're just happy so they don't need to
go out and try to achieve some stupid
[ __ ] goals so they can then get
trashed
on twitter
so anyways they go she actually flies
those giant cargo
planes with like the three tanks in the
back that they drop out with the [ __ ]
parachutes
and i'm like you [ __ ] me like that's
unbelievable
right i'm blown away and then she points
to a friend and goes ah this is my
friend
uh she used to be a cheerleader for this
professional football team right
they tell me that and now i'm thinking
[ __ ] i'm like all right you're a
[ __ ] pilot
not saying the other girl wasn't good
looking but i'm kind of drunk at this
point because i haven't eaten
i only had two beers that was the thing
i only had two [ __ ] beers but i even
had two beers
the level of [ __ ] i am at stone sober
two beers in
i say the law head i go i just you know
kind of whispered to him i go there's no
way sh
she was a cowboys cheerleader she her
rack isn't big enough and then she just
goes clear as day
did you just say my rack isn't big
enough
i felt like a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm
thinking i thought i whispered that
evidently i yelled it over the [ __ ]
music
um and then i had to try and talk my way
out of that i wasn't saying she wasn't
good looking but you know you watch them
on tv they make it look like they all
got [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] very least 34c all the way up to
d
cup titties they make them look perfect
most of them are probably fake
it's like the fake t i told her i said
look every chick out there has fake
titties in in
dallas this is me flailing trying to get
out of it or trying to like i felt bad i
should just apologize i wasn't drunk
really
you can't apologize for that i said it
she heard it
i'm an [ __ ] but when i did say it was
like the fake titty cap of the world
she did give me a high five and i
thought i was fine but later on when i
walked out i walked by i think it was
her husband
she had a wedding ring on and i walked
by this guy and i thought he was waving
to me he holds up his cell phone and i
see that there's a picture of a dallas
cowboy cheerleader
on it so i think it was his wife which
means she went over and told him
and i want to thank that guy she told
you when you didn't smash a bottle over
my head i really want to i appreciate it
my fault uh next time i come out there
i'll buy you
some [ __ ] i don't know what whatever
the poo poo platter whatever the [ __ ]
they have out there
it's brutal so that's why i try to drink
at home
you know what i'm gonna do say something
rude to my dog
ah jesus i'm really too old to have
continued to have new stories like this
anyways all right bill what's my move
i'm a sophomore in college
and not very experienced with
relationships um i met this girl about
three weeks ago in class and she seems
pretty cool
we've been hanging out progressively
more often during the last couple of
weeks
i feel like i've been getting signs from
her but i'm pretty confused now
she comes to my room and we hang out on
the bed
lying close to each other oh god dude
she's waiting for you to make a move
that's what your next move is make a
move
we hang out on my bed lying close to
each other and do homework
or watch a movie or whatever she also
texts me every day so yesterday we
kissed for the first time there you go
you're in the game
now batting right
when they bring in the substitute guy
and all those nerds are keeping score
start [ __ ] erasing [ __ ] you know
now batting a virgin out of des moines
iowa
um anyways so yesterday
we kissed for the first time before she
left about 20 minutes after
i get a text from her with about six
paragraphs
explaining how she kind of has a
boyfriend
but he treats her like [ __ ] so it's
pretty much
over ah jesus
you know what there's always a price to
pay
no matter what you do it's like that guy
who doesn't want to drink anymore
who wants to taper it down there's a
price he's going to pay
and the price he's going to pay is he's
going to be sitting there doing the
right thing not drinking
wishing that he could just sit there and
[ __ ] pound 20 beers
you know but he wants to take control of
his [ __ ] life and the price he has to
pay
is he can't ever do that again and then
there's the other side you drink the 20
[ __ ] beers and then you know the
price you pay
look at the price i paid after having
two [ __ ] lightweight you know
so here you go you finally make the move
you kiss her
there's always a [ __ ] price
so you got to ask yourself son are you
willing to pay this price
if you continue i'm not going to read
the rest of this because i can tell you
right now
there is possibly a [ __ ]
beat down slash double murder
slash maybe double murder suicide
at the end of this [ __ ] rainbow
um anyways i'll read the rest he goes
and also she explains
how she's not ready for a relationship
we can still cuddle
i don't know about this yeah [ __ ] this
chick
he goes i'm trying to get my dick wet
but she also seems cool
you're trying to get your dick wet this
dude's not a virgin you're speaking that
you're speaking the language
trying to get your dick wet yeah you for
you [ __ ] this is the pistol [ __ ]
formation
all right you kissed her that's the mesh
point
you got to do a zone read here what's
going on what's going on right here
on two or two ready break right
come on dude you know what the [ __ ] you
gotta do
right now you know what you seem like a
guy who got laid hasn't got laid for a
while so now or maybe you really like
this girl
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on
all right
let me just read the rest of this
[ __ ] things like two more sentences
says i just don't want to be in the same
position for the next two months
should i give a [ __ ] about this girl am
i getting bullshitted
yeah you're getting bullshitted
she wants to get out of the relationship
but she doesn't want to be lonely
all right this is what you should say to
say look
all right i think uh you know i don't do
that
i don't kiss girls who have boyfriends i
don't do that stuff
and uh i don't hang out with them laying
on beds
i would love to lay in a bed and kiss
you if you did not have a boyfriend
so i think it would be best if uh when
that situation clears up
you know then come by
you know but you know wait a while give
the guy an opportunity to see you know
if he's gonna kill you or not so i don't
get caught in the crossfire
after you know two three months he
doesn't kill you i know it's safe and uh
i will gladly bang you in my
uh my [ __ ] bed my single
that's how i'd handle it that's how i
should have handled that at your age but
there weren't podcasts
so i just had to listen to my dick
ah [ __ ] there it was there it was it
took me 50 [ __ ] minutes to be funny
but there it was all right
fiancee's ex hey bill i really
appreciate the show it keeps me sane in
the cubicle farm well god bless you for
[ __ ]
fighting the good fight out there um now
to the meat of the email
look at this guy he thanks me in like a
sentence and a half and he gets right to
it
this is how you do it people this is
textbook
uh he goes my fiancee who i love dearly
has an ex-boyfriend she maintains
a friendship with [ __ ] drop this
[ __ ]
right now sorry knee-jerk reaction
continuing listening without prejudice
um i am of the mindset that men and
women cannot maintain that kind of
relationship
thank you preach on
especially if there was some kind of
dating involved
in the past uh
i am not comfortable with this guy
and i am struggling with this struggling
with this [ __ ] um should i straight out
tell the [ __ ] i don't like him being
around or do i take the more painful
approach and pretend everything's cool
one other quick question i have to make
a run to new mex mexico soon and wanted
to snag the name of that italian place
you were talking about
on the podcast or so back ah [ __ ] you
know what it's right next to a hilton
garden inn
and it begins with a b
like bueno buena something like that
come on somebody in new mexico helped
this guy out
um and send it to me and i'll read it
next week i'll figure it out by next
week
all right that's a promise but anyways
yeah dude you got you got
you gotta this is this is not cool at
all
it's not cool at all all right
that's not cool at all guys do not
continue
being friends with women i think women
maybe can do it but guys can't do it
he's trying to he's trying to [ __ ]
he's gonna try to bang her
dude that's [ __ ] this is your fiance
you can't [ __ ] have that
you can't have that
you know and uh
this is what you gotta do you gotta tell
her that and when she gets mad and she
gets upset
what you know trust me blah blah blah
blah blah blah
you have to sit there and totally
maintain your cool do not take the bait
if she starts calling you names if she's
a name call and all that do not get
upset
just say that like that [ __ ] i did in my
act
we will discuss this later when you calm
down i don't want to argue about this
um i don't think it's fair the position
you're putting me in
and um i would never do that to you i
would never hang out
with an ex-girlfriend of mine
all right i don't think that that's cool
so i would appreciate it if you would
not do that anymore
and if she continues to do it then um
i would marry somebody else personally
you know i'm not cool with that in my
relationship
i've had to deal with that you know
i've had to deal with that a couple of
times well you know it's just kind of as
afraid of he took an acting class
like no no i literally had to explain do
you think he's
yes yes he is he has tried to he has
tried to yes
exactly you know
or maybe he's he's hoping that you have
hot friends that he can try and [ __ ]
by you know being the guy who hangs out
with the chicks
you know maybe he's trying to do that
but he's trying to [ __ ] something
and if you're the only thing around he's
gonna try and [ __ ] you so no it's not
cool
um anyways all right next one this is
all [ __ ] guys talking about the
ladies this week
um stay with girl or not all right hi
bill love the podcast thank you and in a
tough situation so i would like to know
your thoughts
i've been with a girl for five months
and a few weeks into it she mentioned
she had been in a relationship for five
years
and is still friends with the guy what
the [ __ ] is this the same one
i already answered this who i've met and
who wasn't a bad dude she used to talk
to him a lot
so she seemed not over him and mentioned
that they were basically [ __ ] buddies
since breaking up
which i don't mind happening but do mind
her thinking it's no biggie to tell me
all right let me let me try and do the
math on that
she mentioned they were basically [ __ ]
buddies since breaking up which i don't
mind happening
but do mind her thinking it's no biggie
to tell me so you don't mind if she's
[ __ ] this guy in the side
just don't bring it up wasn't there an r
b song about that
something about girl i don't want to
know something
i can't [ __ ] remember anyways it
seemed like it was a recent breakup
but when i asked her she said in a
roundabout way it was about two years
ago
about two months in she admitted that
she had last slept with them
the week after she met me which was
actually the night of the day we met up
for the first time so after our first
date
this sounds dumb but otherwise things
are good
and she's tone talking about him down
since and is a good girl different to a
lot of
ones in my past which is why i stayed
with her after that
this girl's [ __ ] your brains out
that's what's going on
she likes sex and i guarantee you she
[ __ ] this guy
at least one more time after your first
date
that this that's my instinct i'm not
saying that's true that's just my
instinct
anyways it says i'm 25 and haven't had a
girlfriend
before out of not wanting to settle and
enjoy being single
exactly there we go you haven't had a
girlfriend before so you don't know how
to set up a relationship yeah cause
you're setting this one up
dude come on you gotta have some
self-worth here okay
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this isn't the mother you
kids she's got a [ __ ] buddy
bangs him one time after your first date
obviously she wasn't seeing fireworks
the [ __ ] is she doing with you all right
let her blow you one more time and show
her the [ __ ] door
sorry got emotional i'll i'll let's
respect this and i'll read the rest uh
though i was getting sick
of the single life when i got with her
and we'd be bummed out with the prospect
of getting laid less than once a month
yeah
you know something you're both using
each other
uh you're five months in i really hope
you're not in love with this girl
said i have graduated and want to move
out of our city partly to move in with a
really good
friend who i miss who lives interstate
and she still has one year to go and
doesn't seem keen on moving
in your words based on that one incident
i think i already told you
i don't think she's going to be the
mother of my children here he is and
i'll always think
of it when i tell people how we met i
feel i could be missing out
on advancing my career and being with my
best friend
as i've grown apart from my other
friends as well as getting out of my
shitty small town do you think i should
move out and cut this thing short abs
are [ __ ] lootly and you know you
should
get out of your shitty small town [ __ ]
this this girl
she's gonna be in that same bar every
[ __ ] christmas when you come home to
visit your parents
okay she's going to be there and every
year her face is going to get a little
fatter and she might have more ink on
her [ __ ] arm
and you are going to be moving on with
your life all right and then one day
you're not going to want to go back to
that bar you're just going to drive by
it
and you're going to be like i wonder if
she's in there and you're not going to
give a [ __ ] because the girl you your
dreams is going to be in your passenger
seat and you're going to drive right by
on this perfectly [ __ ] snow-covered
road
there's a picture for you but that's
only going to happen if you dump this
[ __ ]
and get out of that small shitty town
all right that was a good one huh um
okay olive garden chronicles
hey billy boy i am a 24 year old
part-time college student
working at olive garden and this new
chick here has been a real flirt towards
me
uh i see just about all the signs she
always tells me how delicious i
smell gross how bad she wants to play
with
my hair okay one time when i was testing
out a drink she took the glass
rotate it to the part where my mouth
wasn't drank on it from there
disgusting all right
so you know she swallows um
so what do you plan on taking old ass to
mouth
sorry for some reason i found that hot
oh this guy's [ __ ] hilarious
everything about her was
was uh everything about it was
incredible figure
nice tits and glasses made her look even
sexier with her pinned up hair
one big problem this is a game changer
she's
17. oh dee
dude she's got major [ __ ] daddy
issues come on dude
there's plenty of [ __ ] that are of age
uh
do i really need to read the rest of
this
we got off at the same time the other
night and just started talking outside
oh
dude if this [ __ ] goes to some sexual
thing if i read it is am i part of the
[ __ ] crime
is 17 legal in your state some states it
is just a good old boy
um i did the gentleman thing and asked
her if she needed a ride home
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't lie to me huh i thought we were
friends
you calling me up you're asking for
advice and then you 40 think i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you didn't do the gentleman thing your
dick was [ __ ] pushing through your
zipper
and you're like you want to ride home
you want to [ __ ] ruin this girl
tried to do the generally thing you [ __ ]
you know what i
just for that i shouldn't even read the
rest of this but i'm too [ __ ]
interested
um she politely declined and said her
sister wants to pick her up
adding that she doesn't want to use me
like that she also said she was afraid
that she might get you
used to it and expect it every time we
work together
understandable it's not understandable
she's [ __ ]
jerking you around she's putting on a
goddamn [ __ ]
pg-13 sex show
you know inside the bar and then you get
outside hey there's my car
you want to just [ __ ] continue on
with your little show no that's okay
this might be one of these girls that
get your dick [ __ ] you know
hard as a [ __ ] rock and then just
walks away just wants to see you chase
it and the only way you're gonna get it
is if you just [ __ ] walk away from it
and she'll follow you home like a lost
puppy but she's 17 so you don't want
that to happen
um anyways however she asked me to stick
around and keep her company until her
ride comes
she asked me where i usually hang out
dude can i am am i going to get in
trouble for this [ __ ] i'm not reading
the rest of this she's always
she's only 17. why don't you call kip
winger he'll tell you what the [ __ ] to
do
i say walk away all right
the only question you should be asking
her is when are you turning
when she says why say because i'll tell
you on your birthday
all righty that's the podcast for this
week everybody um
bittersweet this week you know uh
rondo went down toward his acl i [ __ ]
love the celtics i really do and i know
there's a lot of people that hate the
boston celtics but you know something
if i can appreciate the fact that paul
gasol is a great basketball
player and kobe bryant now you gotta
even as a laker fan come on
you gotta you gotta you have to admit
unless you're just a straight up [ __ ]
the [ __ ] celtics got more heart than
any other team in the league
you know they do you know they do
i'm telling you they will fight you to
the end even [ __ ] kobe said it he
said the celtics never [ __ ] quit
and if you guys think that because rondo
has gone down that this team is gonna
roll over you're out of your [ __ ]
minds
all right the only way this team rolls
over is if danny ainge and those guys
break it up that's the only way
that's the only [ __ ] way and i was
flying
to god knows [ __ ] where and i missed
that whole celtics heat game but i have
been watching the bruins
i watch them come back tonight um
after the hurricanes tied it up
hurricanes look good man
great goaltender [ __ ] the cuntiest
four checking i've ever seen
uh but we somehow survived it but
they're a great team we got the devils
tomorrow night
when they're always great so uh i can't
believe how much i missed hockey
when it came back i just absolutely
[ __ ] love it it's the greatest
goddamn sport and i love that most
people think it sucks
please by all means continue to not
watch it
i love it's great
being the fourth most popular sport it's
great you know what that's like
that's like being like uh
what's that like being it's like being
the bass player in this [ __ ] awesome
band
and you're just collecting checks but
when you walk off stage nobody
recognizes you nobody gives a [ __ ]
they're all running all over to the
singer
and they complete guitarist and you get
to live a life
go down on the beach drink a [ __ ]
six-pack with your rockstar money you
know
you got enough money to get a
good-looking [ __ ] woman
you gotta deal with the [ __ ] what am
i talking about i can't remember what
the [ __ ] what was i just talking about
being a hockey fan it's great
i'm sorry guys i'm i i was i've been on
four planes in three days all right
there's my excuse i'm limping home all
right that's the podcast for this week
as always uh if you want to buy
something on amazon.com and donate to
the monday morning podcast just go to
the podcast page
on billboard.com we have a banner ad you
click right on the amazon
uh banner takes you right to amazon and
you're on there you don't have to do
anything else
everything's still the same price they
kicked me a percentage i take a
percentage of that actually percentage
of all my advertising 10
to be exact and i give it to the wounded
warriors project you'll be supporting
this podcast
and uh and the wounded warriors project
and uh that is it that's the podcast for
this week go [ __ ] yourselves
enjoy the super bowl uh give it a shot
if you haven't already committed
to a super bowl party if you're already
committed still tape the game at home
okay and then just sit down and watch it
and look for that play
i'm gonna look forward to the pistol
[ __ ] formation
i can't even what the [ __ ] it's called
do you love when they say that [ __ ] now
that
it's basically a hot read the [ __ ] are
you talking about
john gruden did you come out with a book
and explain it to me what is the cover 2
defense all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll talk to you next week
she's she's a this is not it doesn't
seem like this is the girl for you she
might be a little too
advanced will you stop alligator armani
this might not be the girl for you she's
a little too advanced this woman is a
[ __ ] war pig
you're alright i'm not i'm trying to be
like tender and
you know nice you know what alligator
armor means you don't watch sports
no i don't you know what i really don't
appreciate
when i come down here and having this
conversation with you and you want to
throw these little sports things at me
and you always
you always say oh you don't watch sports
or you don't get the sports thing like
you have to like remind me
that i'm not on the same level as you
like so i'm not going to get all your
amazing sports references and terms and
phrases
and i don't appreciate that can you guys
believe
that within 10 minutes of just going on
this rant about how dumb i am and how
innocent i am with using the word [ __ ]
and i i don't
you have like an innocent heart but
you're dumb
and you you just respond with rage the
whole way you made me this [ __ ]
like simpleton yeah you'd be doing
everything but [ __ ] you know
being a big goof like hey what are you
doing like walking down the street like
you know and accidentally crushed
somebody to death trying to hug them
that's how you just painted me you're
like yeah you're like of a mice and men
yeah that's how you're painting me
within 10 minutes of this
you're a lenny and of mice and men
that's how you do yeah that's exactly
how you described me
i was too dumb to know that [ __ ]
reference
and then because i i say alligator arm
is
okay you've seen an alligator right yeah
do they have long arms no they do not
they do not and it's basically it's a uh
it's a sports term um
somebody throws you the ball and you
could actually reach out and get it but
you don't totally reach out because
you're worried about getting hit
okay sort of so you alligator arm it's
like
so and if you don't catch the ball the
guy can't hit you oh okay
i thought so i'm saying yo so your
alligator arm in this in that you're
going
this girl isn't the girl for you but
blah blah blah he's in
he's he's in there with the [ __ ] pit
viper right
he's the goat and she's the people
he is the std free goat and he is
walking into a [ __ ]
incubator of just i mean
i mean this girl probably i don't know i
i i want to get into she's not the girl
for you
she's not the girl for you that's bad
advice
why this girl i'm telling you it's a
[ __ ] pig
and what is she supposed to do about it
tell the whole [ __ ] school i'm just
not
she's not the girl for you move on to
somebody else who's more your speed why
is that bad advice
because you're acting like you know
she's
not into sports likes to eat and is a
morning person
and he likes sports and staying up you
know what
this person isn't like you know this
person isn't for you
i mean it's like a foodie it's like it's
a simple
way of saying that that you know you
should move on that's that's all it is
no it's like you're sitting there with
the toddler and he's about ready to
touch a hot stove
you got to be like there has to be a
sense of urgency here
like like no no no no no this this will
hurt you
this will hurt you know you make the
little [ __ ] can they don't even speak
english you're trying to [ __ ]
you're sitting there talking to this
person like um
hey try some of this sandwich yeah i
didn't really like that bread well maybe
you like this bread like
it's just like this whimsical there's
too many daisies and what you're saying
this is this is a very dangerous
situation this guy should stay away from
this girl
on all [ __ ] and all girls like this
she's got a she's on her period and she
has no [ __ ] like like
class she just opens her leg
like what was he supposed to do pull it
out and just go off on it there's other
ways she's suggesting anal this girl is
like
she's a [ __ ] mess stay away from this
girl this girl
will get pregnant this girl will give
you [ __ ] a disease this girl will
steal your laptop this girl's a [ __ ]
nightmare
knock it off all right all right advice
for a lady
dear bill i've been with my boyfriend
for two years now
we're in college together and he's
currently taking a semester abroad
oh jesus where in brazil
um before he left we had a running joke
that i was going to need a vibrator when
he left
as a surprise parting gift he got me one
i have a couple friends whose boyfriends
bought them sex
toys so while i was a little surprised
he actually got me a vibrator
i also happen to know that it's a
relatively normal
it's relatively normal for a boyfriend
to do that yeah that's basically like
this era's chastity belt
you know you're trying to lock down the
[ __ ]
that's disgusting hey yeah but that's
what he's doing though
anyway yeah but it's done because those
things you use them too much they numb
up your area there and then the guy
can't even remotely try and
you know
do something for and then you got to be
sitting there banging them as their user
using the thing as you know it's like
you and an alien are [ __ ] this girl
is this an alien
that's just all dick has no body
all right whatever let's move on what am
i basing it on based on my my [ __ ]
life
i did live a little bit of a life before
i met you i realized that
all right anyway fast forward to about a
week ago
we were on skype oh he asked you to take
this thing out
um no we don't have sex chats thank god
and he casually asked me
how his gift for me was working out i
told him it was working out pretty well
he then mentioned that he had bought
something for himself
a fleshlight
joe rogan experience is brought to you
by the fleshlight every week
those are very weird those are very
[ __ ] okay they look like that thing
boba fett
fell into when he died in one of those
space movies
okay well um i knew he was trying to be
faithful to her that's nice
okay he said she goes i knew what this
was because i am an average listener of
joe rogan's podcast
there you go joe rogan's come up three
times in this podcast
who raves about it constantly my
boyfriend had never mentioned to me
that he was interested in anything like
that and i always thought the idea
of it was totally creepy i acted like it
was totally cool but in all honesty
i really don't want him to be [ __ ] a
perfect
fake wait i got lost in that
i actually was thinking is joe going to
get mad that i'm saying that this is
weird
okay i acted like it was totally cool
but in all honesty i really don't want
him to be [ __ ] a perfect
fake vagina whenever he wants to i'm
finding myself getting crazy
jealous and angry whenever i think about
it
i know i know i'm jealous of an
inanimate object
which seems insane let me finish i'm
really struggling with this be
because part of me wants to be
completely okay with it
since it's sort of a hypocrite it's sort
of hypocritical to get angry when he got
me a vibrator
but now i'm starting to think that maybe
he only bought me a dildo
so i wouldn't be able to complain when
he got himself a proxy [ __ ]
roxy [ __ ] so what do you think do i
need to suck it up and get over this
or is my jealousy legitimate thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself
that's hilarious don't let him go [ __ ]
his fake [ __ ] as long as he's not
faking a real [ __ ] i mean
[ __ ] a real [ __ ] then you know it's
all good
plus you it's not just like the
the [ __ ] that it's that he's missing
he's also missing like
you know your touch and kissing and the
whole other part of it too
and that fake [ __ ] can't below him
either no he isn't he's getting right to
the dessert
don't be jealous have you tried these
brussels sprouts don't need them
don't be jealous bring over the tres
leche when he comes back
it'll be even better because you both
have been like doing it with inanimate
objects and so
it's rediscovering each other all over
again it'll be even better i don't think
so don't even worry i don't think it's a
good thing
why because uh
once you start down a path sexually
you know in order to get off that path
you don't just jump over onto another
path you got to walk all the way back
up the path you went down get to the
fork where you [ __ ] up and then head
down the other one
what i'm saying is he might get used to
just
doing that and the sensation of that
is what gets him off and then when her
[ __ ] doesn't feel like the fleshlight
he'll it'll feel better he'll he'll bang
her
and then and then when he needs to
finish she'll be like all right and now
for me
with that [ __ ] thing no no she'll
feel
even better if anything he'll be like oh
my god i forgot what a real woman
feels like and he'll be done in like two
minutes that's what you hope
um i don't think she should be jealous
of it though they're both
they're both doing the right thing when
you're in a relationship and you're that
far apart from each other because
i bang all sorts of hairy european girls
no offense to hair european girls but
i'm just saying you know listen i i
watched this
thing one time or listen to it on the
radio uh one of those
call in sex shows and this guy
had a way he jerked off because he dry
humped the rug
it was causing like chafing on his dick
in him but it it was the only way he
could get off because he wasn't in a
relationship for a while and he kept
doing that
and i don't know so i'm just saying like
i would go easy on those
it's like anything anything in
moderation yeah how often is he using
this
and how often is she using that if you
use a vibrator too much you numb
yourself up down there and then when
your guys down there you can't feel
anything
that's so disgusting um overrated
underrated for the week
overrated the super bowl underrated
rounds one and two of the nfl playoffs
bill this may be sacrilegious to say in
america but i actually enjoy
rounds one and two of the nfl playoffs
more than the super bowl
that isn't sacri-religious because at no
point does beyonce or britney spears
sing before and in the halftime show
there's not a bunch of douchebags who
don't like football showing up
feeling like they have to be there you
know
all the broads why are you yeah why are
you looking at me because
you go to super bowl parties every year
and you hate football
yeah well they're fun they're nice
gatherings and they can talk when the
game's on i like
no i don't think they'll run when the
most
important game is on it's disgusting
if you do it again this year we're
breaking up each week
you get two games both on saturday and
sunday
there seems to be that we can win this
thing excitement in the air
and i can relax and watch the games in
the comfort of my home
or a local bar without dozens of
non-fans in the room
as is typically the case at a super bowl
party super bowl on the other hand has
become so pretentious in recent years
i don't even really want to get worked
up for it as much as i used to
the game takes forever 85 percent of the
commercial sucks
and we're forced to stare at madonna's
beat up face for 30 minutes during a
halftime show
plus the two-week gap in between the
super bowl and the conference champion
really takes the air out of the sales
what are your thoughts i think this is
what you do you watch the super bowl
alone
and you tape it and you start watching
it you dvr
it and you watch you let you let you
give the game a 90 minute head start
and then then you just sit down you
watch it by yourself
and you you plow through the pre-game
and you just watch the [ __ ] game and
when the halftime show comes you fast
forward through that
and now you're into the third quarter
and third quarter and fourth quarter
it's going to be regular time football
that's the way to watch the super bowl
and you watch it by yourself
maybe with another buddy of yours who
that uh enjoys the game that's how i
would do it
you know no thoughts on that no but what
about the
social aspects shut up we were gonna
have
brownies during the opening and you're
going to have cheese doodles
oh my god the way the broads talk during
that [ __ ] game and then and then
and it's true and then everybody shuts
up to watch the commercials
and then and then the game comes back on
the uh i thought that one was lame
what did you think well that's
definitely the best one so far
how much did that cost well why don't
you stop going
to super bowl parties then bill why
don't you
stop if you don't like the game i don't
do any of that stuff that you're talking
about i don't know
i don't like needlepoint i don't go to
your [ __ ] needlepoint parties
needlepoint i don't do anything what do
you do arts and crafts i don't crash
your super bowl or those things
and come there and talk when you're
trying to glue the popsicle sticks
together
and then shut the [ __ ] up when i talk
throughout the game i go in the other
room
or i hang out with other people if
there's live slides lies yeah
[Music]
okay that's the monday morning podcast
oh before i get out of here
huh that's it that's it we did a nice
long one all right there's nothing else
huh no okay um amazon.com everybody if
you want to
um if you want to uh buy something on
amazon.com and support my podcast go to
billboard.com click on the podcast page
take it we got a link um whatever you
call it the little box a little window
thing the little uh
little icon you click on that thing i
have no idea what they're called
the banner ad you click on it you go to
amazon.com you buy something they kick
me back a little bit of money i take 10
of that and i throw it to the wounded
warriors project you you sponsor this
and the wounded warriors see that's it
everybody that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves and uh
yeah you ever get with a girl and she
spreads her leg with the the rip cord
there
all right you're the goat she's the
snake get the [ __ ] out of the cage